fedex
l'ho sempre vista come un qualcosa di
interessante quasi irraggiungibile
quelli che parlavano ai vari ted nate ed
ex sempre detto ma come fanno a fare uno
speech così bene trovare i contenuti ma
non ce la farò mai
è un paio di mesi fa ho ricevuto una
chiamata
mi è stato chiesto se volevo partecipare
ad ex alunni di udine
cosa ho pensato fedex è roba da grandi
sarò all'altezza e non stavo pensando
alla statura dopo netto ma sì dai
proviamo e così eccomi qua vedrete
giudicherete voi se se sono all'altezza
o meno di cosa vi parlo di i limiti di
traguardi di sogni e anche di disabilità
parto della disabilità perché userò
questo termine in un paio di occasioni
durante il mio intervento è spesso la
disabilità viene viene considerato viene
usato questo termine in modo secondo me
errato ma vediamo che cosa vuol dire
allora ho preso il dizionario e sono
andato proprio a leggere la definizione
che vi leggo testualmente disabile
termine in uso nel linguaggio
burocratico sociologico è anche medico
riferito a soggetti che abbiano qualche
minorazione fisica o anche psichica di
relativamente non grave sinonimo
handicappato minorato menomato invalido
vediamo allora minorato vediamo cosa
vuol dire minorato andato sulla m vedo
minorazione il render o diventare minore
calor diminuzione scadimento valere meno
sono una persona con disabilità quindi
valgo meno però la definizione dello
stesso anche per deriva dall'inglese e
quindi ho preso il dizionario cose che
se inglese e vediamo cosa dice allora è
perso
erika fisica dormendo al condition
l'altra street band in the ability to
move for users senses cioè una una
condizione fisica o mentale che riduce
le abilità a muoversi o nell'uso dei
sensi
ma cosa significa allora ability sempre
lezionario ability is the quality horsky
dati where will make it possible for you
to something si parla di skill vediamo
cosa significa screen is the new dance
ability data enabled to something well
quindi in inglese disabilità è
semplicemente la mancanza di conoscenza
o di capacità nel fare qualcosa bene o
come come possono fare altri
capite che sono due definizioni
totalmente diverse quindi la persona
disabile è una persona che non vale
niente vale poco
oppure è semplicemente una persona che
fa determinate cose in un modo diverso o
non è in grado di fare determinate cose
secondo me è questa seconda definizione
quella corretta squadra inglese
da qua forse la mia passione non sempre
stato un appassionato del mondo
anglosassone
mi piace molto viaggiare da girata in
lungo e largo della gran bretagna
adesso preparando questo tetto ed
essendo queste definizioni
forse ho capito qual'era questo motivo
così sconosciuto a me che mi porta ad
amici
il mondo anglosassone però non è solo
una definizione su un dizionario è
proprio una questione di mentalità in
italia effettivamente ci sono ancora
tantissime persone che considerano la
persona disabile una persona che vale
meno ed ogni cosa ogni obiettivo che è
una persona disabile raggiunge è
qualcosa di straordinario
proprio perché se uno non vale niente
anche se fa poco è qualcosa di
straordinario
nella definizione del sassone invece è
semplicemente una persona come tutte le
altre che ha esigenze diverse
gli ho detto che vi parlo di limiti che
cos'è un limite un limite è un punto un
punto di arrivo e un punto di arrivo
dove quando mi avvicino a questo limite
partendo anche dalla definizione
matematica la funzione che tende ad un
limite
il comportamento cambia quindi quando mi
avvicino al mio limite
e bello studiare che cosa succede che
cosa cosa cambia e anche nelle persone
ogni persona ha i suoi limiti e le
persone si comportano in modo diverso
avvicinandosi a questo limite quando
nasciamo i primi mesi di vita il nostro
limite muoversi in autonomia quindi
riuscire a portarsi il primo passo che
fa un bambino è quello di arrivare a
gattonare e muoversi
il secondo è mettersi sulle due gambe e
camminare normalmente questo si fa nel
primo anno di vita
nel mio caso è successo a tre anni i
primi anni di vita mia vita ho subito
diversi interventi e che mi hanno
portato a convivere con spesso con dei
gessi
questo però non mi ha comportato
l'impossibilità di muovermi ho
cominciato a camminare a tre anni ma
come tutti gli altri bambini io
ascoltavo per casa non gattonando ma
trascinandomi spostandomi ho provato il
mio modo per muovermi facendo anche le
scale con i miei genitori che
impazzivano vedendomi andare su e giù
per le scale con i gessi saltellando da
scalino all'altro quindi che cosa è il
limite il limite è un qualcosa di nostro
arriviamo a un certo punto e a questo
punto le persone cosa fanno o si fermano
perché davanti a un limite ci si ferma
oppure cercano di superarlo e cerco di
superarlo ho raggiunto un traguardo
quando raggiunto un traguardo
cosa faccio sposto avanti il limite
quindi quel traguardo è una bandierina
nella mia storia
nella mia vita appunto guardo avanti
vedo quale il prossimo limite e cerco di
raggiungerlo secondo limite che ho
incontrato nella mia vita era un
qualcosa di semplicissimo andare in
bagno da solo
anche qui i bambini normalmente imparano
a 3 anni 2 anni 34 dipende da chi ci
arriva prima o dopo
io sono riuscito a essere completamente
indipendente più o meno verso i 6 anni e
vi ricordo che per me è stato un grande
traguardo un grande successo tant'è che
buongiorno sono arrivato dalla maestra
dietro maestra oggi vado a fare la pipì
da solo quindi questo questo mio limite
ha messo un'altra bandierina un altro
traguardo e mi ha fatto guardare avanti
e cercare un altro traguardo da
raggiungere perché questo mi da i
simboli mi dà la possibilità di vivere e
di essere all'interno dell'ambiente che
ci circonda
a modo mio ma come tutti gli altri
quando si dice che le persone con
disabilità hanno dei problemi e delle
necessità
sì è vero però spesso queste necessità
sono create dall ambiente in cui viviamo
non sono specifiche della persona perché
se noi vivessimo in un
in un posto dove tutte le case tutto
quanto forse alto un metro e trenta
io vivrei benissimo però le persone che
con delle disabilità sarebbero tutti gli
altri quindi io sì cerco di forme dei
limiti dei traguardi e di adattarmi
all'ambiente
però se anche l'ambiente forse pensato
per essere all'altezza di tutti
tutti quanti mi verrebbero un po meglio
ha proseguito siamo sono cresciuto ho
iniziato a studiare come ragioniera e
proprio per diventare la regina
ragioniere programmatore durante
l'estate
andavo ad aiutare mio nonno che aveva un
piccolo negozio di alimentari e stavo in
casa facevano un po di conti gli
scontrini eccetera
anche qui le persone che incontravo mi
sembrava che facessi qualcosa di
straordinario sto studiando ragioneria
diventa ragioniere fare uno scontrino
non è niente di così straordinario però
c'è questa mentalità di considerare la
persona con delle disabilità con un
valore inferiore e quindi il semplice
battere uno scontrino che lo può fare
chiunque ma comunque sta studiando e
ragioneria è una cosa semplicissima
veniva vista come qualcosa di
straordinario da qui ha continuato la
mia vita nel 3 a 20 anni fa e mi sono
preso lo sfizio anche di prendere il
brevetto di volo ultraleggero sono
andato con un collega mi è piaciuto
chiesto a istruttore scusa posso farlo
anch'io
sì non anche questo per me non era nulla
di straordinario
semplicemente aveva delle necessità di
adattamento sul velivolo ma come cederò
ad esempio sulla macchina preso la
patente e ho imparato a volare usando
queste
questi adattamenti quando ho preso il
brevetto destato l'interesse per stampa
media locali nazionali sembrava forse il
campione del mondo di non so quale
disciplina quando per me l'hanno fatto
ha nulla di più straordinario rispetto a
quanto avessero fatto i miei compagni di
corso
anzi io ritengo che il vero protagonista
del mio brevetto di volo e chi ha
trovato il modo per adattare l'aereo
quindi come dicevo prima è l'ambiente in
cui viviamo che crea del problematico
delle necessità perché se tutti gli
aerei fossero costruiti forse rapì come
potevo usarlo io probabilmente una
persona che non alle mie necessità
riuscirebbe comunque a pilotarlo ma
riesco anch'io
e questo è il si chiama del pensiero
inclusivo e proprio da questo pensiero
inclusivo un po di anni fa ho deciso di
creare qualcosa che potesse aiutare a
diffondere questa cultura
ho avuto un creato un sogno un sogno che
è il terzo set limite traguardo sogno il
sogno che cosa è un qualcosa che ancora
indefinito
non si sa bene se lo raggiungerò quando
lo raggiungerò però per arrivarci devo
pormi dei limiti devo superarli formi
dei traguardi mette i paletti e prima o
poi dopo una serie di traguardi
raggiunti riuscirò a realizzare anche il
sogno adesso il mio sogno è di creare
una società che ho già creato bisogno
che abbia successo che possa veramente
contribuire a rendere più semplice la
vita di molte persone persone che non
sono solo disabili ma chiunque abbia
delle necessità legate all'accessibilità
perché come abbiamo visto nella
definizione inglese
ogni persona può avere può essere abile
o meno avere le capacità o meno di fare
delle determinate azioni
il fatto di non riuscire a fare
determinate azioni in un certo modo
determina una necessità quindi con la
startup che ho aperto dove cercare di
aiutare queste persone fornendo
informazioni quindi informazioni
sull'ambiente sui luoghi per far sì che
possano muoversi in modo consapevole e
in questo modo facilitare la diffusione
di un pensiero inclusivo che vada oltre
quella definizione italiana brutta del
disabile che è una persona che non ha
valore per concludere e dire che
qui nella mia vita si sono sempre stato
uno intraprendente ho cercato di
superare i miei limiti
ogni limite portava a guardare avanti e
formano un altro non mi sono mai fermato
davanti a un limite
la cosa che mi piacerebbe che sto
cercando di trasmettere quando parlo con
le persone è questo di vedere anche le
persone con disabilità per quello che
valgono
io voglio che le persone mi considerano
per il mio valore
non per la mia altezza o che per il
fatto che abbia qualcuno dice senato
sfortunato si no non lo so non so cosa
sarebbe successo come sarei perché
persona sarei stato se fossi nato in un
modo diverso
fatto sta che sono nato così e mi sono
adattato diciamo all'ambiente in cui
vivo ho fatto la mia vita ha raggiunto i
miei traguardi alcuni più straordinari
alcuni meno però sono come tutti gli
altri
quindi il messaggio vorrei dare oggi qui
a questo tex è quello di considerare le
persone per ciò che realmente valgono e
tralasciando l'aspetto e la condizione
in cui si trovano gli occhi a tutti
[Applauso]